[Music]
welcome back breaking the glass ceiling
that's the title of a new book for
Latino entrepreneurs joining me this
morning CEO and co-founder of she Rises
Studios Hannah Olivas thank you so much
for being here this morning the day
after 4th of July nice and early but
you've got first of all you have a
company with a couple different prongs
and a book that's coming out that really
is geared toward Latina women why is it
so important to focus on Latina women
well number one I'm Latina and number
two I feel we are still super
underrepresented we are a huge force of
men and women in business who are the
fifth largest economy in the world and
we're just not represented enough so
this book that we're going to talk about
talks about all of those different
things and how each one of us as
entrepreneurs women because that's who's
in the book have broken the glass
ceiling is there pointers for women who
are looking you know maybe younger women
coming up but folks in college still on
how to really do that because they're
it's not so easy
it is not so easy there's a ton of
pointers we have these women who have
co-authored this book with me are
incredible and when you pick up this
book and you read it and you're looking
for that guidance those strategies it's
there I think we've covered all bases
and really we want to make sure that the
message is clear that we're here we want
to bridge that wealth Gap and we want to
be the majority we don't want to be
looked at as the minority and the
driving force I'm guessing by creating
this book you have your own company she
Rises Studios what uh I mentioned
different prongs obviously writing
publishing what else does your company
do so we just recently launched in the
last month and a half Phoenix TV okay so
we're currently in 120 countries uh we
work with different women all over the
world
um it's it's incredible what we're about
to do with Phoenix TV we also have she
rides the studios podcast
we launched she Rises Latina last year
and
um we're just we really want to be this
platform for women entrepreneurs women
in life and business it's just to
elevate educate and celebrate women on a
global level our strength and numbers I
Hannah how can Folks at home get a hold
of this book because it's not out yet
but it's coming soon
so pre-sales are on Amazon and uh once
the book is released it'll be in all the
major retailers across the country and
in 12 other countries wow well
congratulations on the success that come
company looking out for not only the
book breaking the glass ceiling but also
looking for uh Phoenix as well right
Phoenix I'm so excited about that too
excellent well congratulations thank you
for waking up early with us this morning